hi I'm Devin and I recommend insecure
I think insecure inspires so much
conversation because it's very relatable
and I definitely think like the show
made me feel like ooh the sub so
dramatic but like less alone like I felt
I saw a shared experience make a lot of
times on TV we see them as we see blink
black people or minorities as like
slaves or the maid or like the drug
dealer down the street and we never get
to see them as like a human like a
normal person who like goes to work it
like has like love issues I want to just
see myself like doing normal things like
ordering a taco you know like so yeah I
think I love that aspect of the show and
you really don't get that in a lot of
programming it represents people like me
people like my mother like my sisters
like my brothers that are not always
represented on television and such a
real and honest way and I always am
laughing it's like should be a case
study on how to film people of color
because in their skin and the way they
listen just on the show just like
aesthetically and visually I don't know
I can't name any other show or like
people of color look so great yeah I
think Easter ray is a genius like as an
actress as a writer as a director as a
creator I think the work that she puts
forth it really just speaks to her as a
person and like her her desire to
represent voices that aren't heard so
much yeah I Spani sorry
she's definitely retweeted me